noah manoir bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france le
ministre de l'intérieur on lisait gérald
darmanin vient d'arriver sur place
une enquête a été ouverte pour homicide
volontaire après la mort du père olivier
maire et on l'a entendu un beaucoup de
réactions politiques tout au long de la
journée et des interrogations notamment
autour du profil du suspect à il s'agit
d'un rwandais de 40 ans on le disait
mise en examen pour l'incendié de la
cathédrale de nantes il y a un an quel
est votre réaction ce soir
ma première réaction c'est naturellement
de présenter mes condoléances à toute la
communauté catholique de france et du
monde et également de présenter mes
condoléances au peuple vendéen c'est à
dire aux habitants du département de la
vendée qui malgré une réputation un peu
surfaite sont parmi les personnes les
plus accueillantes qu'il m'ait été donné
de rencontrer
donc aujourd'hui ils sont en deuil mais
ils sont aussi particulièrement en
colère et je partage leur colère donc je
suis parmi eux aujourd'hui puisque je me
trouvais en vacances et justement pas
plus tard qu'hier ou avant-hier
je me disais que c'était un climat
vraiment reposant que quand on vient de
seine-saint-denis et qu'on arrive en
vendée quelques culs que quelque part
que ces gens avaient de la chance de
vivre éloigné justement de tous ces
risques du terrorisme du banditisme
extrait de tout ce qu'on connaît en
région parisienne et finalement je me
suis un peu tromper dans mon
appréciation c'est à dire qu'on est à
l'abri nulle part justement de ce type
d'agissement est donc ma réaction d' a
écouté c'est une réaction de
consternation d'indignation je veux dire
ce discours là j'aurais pu vous le tenir
à saint-etienne du rouvray à nice quand
les fidèles en prière ont été assassinés
mais au-delà de ça la gare saint-charles
à quand justement deux françaises ont
été assassinées par un type qui n'avait
absolument rien à faire sur le
territoire qui prétendait au statut de
réfugié et qui aurait dû être expulsé
dont l'arrêté d'expulsion avait été mise
en oeuvre
mais également aux eaux devant les
locaux de l'agencé première ligne à
romans sur isère et la liste est très
longue
elle ne s'arrête pas et qu'à un moment
voilà justement dans un manoir gérald
darmanin lui a expliqué que cet homme ne
pouvait pas être expulsés car il était
sous contrôle judiciaire
alors au vu de la situation de suspects
de ce qu'on sait ce qu'il y avait un
autre suivi judiciaire possible selon
vous non mais écoutez là on est dans des
dans les labyrinthes administrative dont
on a la spécialité en france alors le
message tel que je l'interprète mois
pour le message du ministre de
l'intérieur
c'est de dire à tous les réfugiés qui
sont dans le couloir justement de
l'expulsion aujourd'hui d'aller brûler
une église et vous serez mis à l'abri
justement de l'expulsion administrative
puisque ce monsieur a brûlé une église
et le ministre explique qu'il ne pouvait
pas être expulsé parce qu'il était sous
contrôle judiciaire
donc on vous donne la solution contre
l'expulsion administrative mais on
marche sur la tête
ce monsieur n'avait absolument plus rien
à faire en france il a brûlé une église
à nantes pour un préjudice de plusieurs
millions d'euros qu'il ne pourra
absolument jamais remboursés et
aujourd'hui on nous explique que
finalement son expulsion avait été
différé parce qu'il était mise en cause
par la justice mais c'est à n'y rien
comprendre
la france aujourd'hui est la risée du
reste de l'europe et du monde à cause de
ces lois qui n'obéissent absolument à
aucune logique donc le ministère de
l'intérieur encore une fois comme les
autorités administratives et judiciaires
malgré elles ont failli à leur mission
de sécurisation justement du peuple
français puisque ici la vendée est un
sanctuaire c'est un un département où
les gens vivent en paix un département
prospère économiquement il les risques
sont extrêmement minime mais nous sommes
dans un état de déliquescence et des
compositions de l'institution judiciaire
de l'institution policière qui est telle
qu'aujourd'hui plus rien n'est logique
et justement les citoyens ne sont pas à
l'abri des dangers habituel la priorité
de la police aujourd'hui c'est le
contrôle du paf sanitaire ce n'est plus
la lutte contre la délinquance contre la
criminalité ou contre le terrorisme
alors pas d'actes terroristes
injustement à ce niveau de l'enquète au
vu des éléments connus sur la
personnalité de cet homme notamment
qu'est-ce que voir va devoir déterminer
l'anc est selon vous écouter lors
qu'elle va déterminer les mobiles donc
au regard de ce que je peut en déduire
de ma propre expérience c'est que la
personne s'est rendue elle-même parce
qu'elle est pas si déséquilibrée que
sada sont je pense qu'elle est en
attente d'une indulgence de la part de
la justice l asthme avocat va dire oui
mais il a cédé à quelque chose d'un
souci ça une pulsion meurtrière
et finalement quand il a repris ces
dernières dans ma démission
voilà ce qu'était un succès contre le
peuple aujourd'hui là
en direct devant vous du monde va
écouter voilà je pense que le message
est clair
l'enquète va seront déterminées essayer
de déterminer si la personne est en
pleine possession de ses moyens parce
que ce monsieur espère sans doute passer
au travers des filets de la justice en
psychiatrie dans son propre dossier
moi je n'en sais rien je n'ai pas les
éléments qui me permettent de le
déterminer mais c'est un récidiviste qui
n'avait absolument plus rien à faire ni
en liberté ni en france par ailleurs
alors vous êtes à
saint-laurent-sur-sèvre lahoud en
quelques minutes
gérald darmanin doit s'exprimer quel est
l'état d'esprit de la population des
gens que vous avec qui vous avez pu vous
entretenir autour de vous aujourd'hui
bah écoutez les gens voient ici je
trouve que c'est on est dans une
atmosphère si les plus graves une
atmosphère paradisial et c'est à dire
qu'on a des jeunes en vélo en bmx
skateboard et c'est qu'ils jouissent
justement de la vie du soleil d'un cadre
j'irai quasi encore une fois parfait
pour s'épanouir
mais ils sont absolument choquée par ce
qui s'est passé ils n'en ont pas
l'habitude et ils ont veulent
aujourd'hui aux autorités au ministre de
l'intérieur en particulier de ne pas
avoir su justement les protégés de ce
qui s'est passé
donc les relations avec la gendarmerie
sont très bonnes moi j'ai moi-même été
orientés accueillis par la gendarmerie
les gendarmes du secteur sont totalement
hors de cause dans ce qui s'est passé
ils subissent la mauvaise politique de
ce qui s'est passé de l'institution
policière et judiciaire de nantes qui a
vraisemblablement fait une erreur de
diagnostic qui a conduit justement à ce
drame parce que on peut nous nous si
vous voulez nous rabâcher les leçons de
droit pour nous expliquer que cantonné
sous contrôle judiciaire on n'est pas
expulsable administrativement et c'est
ça ça parle pas aux gens si vous voulez
les gens veulent être en sécurité chez
eux ils veulent jouir de leurs droits de
leur liberté ce monsieur a été accueilli
en france il a été accueilli
généreusement par les vendéens qui l'ont
hébergée qui l'ont accueilli malgré ce
qui l'avait fait précédemment
et cet excès de générosité lors a été
fatal une erreur de diagnostic vous
disiez il aurait dû être expulsé dès
lors finalement que
il a été suspecté d'avoir incendié à la
cathédrale de nantes il aurait dû être
expulsé dans la foulée selon vous alors
dès lors qu'il est suspecté il jouit
effectivement de la présomption
d'innocence mais il ya aussi des indices
de flagrance dans les enquêtes qui
permettent déjà de restreindre ses
libertés fondamentales c'est à dire
qu'on aurait pu le placer en rétention
administrative pendant au moins 90 jours
ce qui n'a sûrement pas été le cas on
aurait pu le placer en hôpital
psychiatrique si on avait déterminé
justement que qu'il ne jouissait pas
toutes ses facultés mentales et on
aurait pu également l'incarcérer parce
que c'est quand vous brûler une église
c'est de la dégradation de biens publics
d'autant que là c'est constant s'est
aggravée quand le bien public est classé
monument historique
donc si vous voulez c'était la dernière
des bonnes idées de le laisser en
liberté après l'église à la culture du
pardon à la culture de la générosité ils
ont décidé de lui donner une seconde
chance mais aujourd'hui force est de
constater qu'ils ont eu tort mais on ne
peut pas les incriminer là dessus qu'est
ce que vous attendez désormais du
gouvernement gérald darmanin doit
s'exprimer dans quelques instants
maintenant qu'est ce que vous attendez
vous de sa parole aujourd'hui rien du
tout absolument rien si vous voulez
s'ils ont échoué pendant cinq ans au
minimum je veux dire c'est pas
aujourd'hui avec des discours qu'on va
pouvoir apaiser la colère populaire
les discours n'apportent absolument rien
ce qu'on a attendu ses des actes mais
bon les élections ont lieu dans moins
d'un semestre maintenant écoutez c'est
pas gérer le le le les discours n'y
changeront absolument rien voilà c'est
moi je j'en attends absolument et
d'ailleurs les journalistes sont en
train d'écouter le discours eux en ce
moment même où un train de s'y préparer
moi je n'y suis pas je suis avec vous je
suis parmi la population parce que
jonathan absolument rien de ce discours
comment ça se passe lors d'un contrôle
ulysse hier est ce que la gendarmerie la
justice était au courant de la situation
du suspect de ceux de ce rwandais de 40
ans la justice savait qu'il logeait dans
cette communauté catholique
ça doit être le cas oui absolument
alors le contrôle judiciaire c'est qu'il
est hébergé donc il bénéficie justement
d'une domiciliation au plan
administratif il se présente au moins
une fois ça peut être deux ou trois fois
au commissariat ou à la gendarmerie
locale pour justement attester de sa
présence est donc ça ça autorise
justement et ça démontre si vous voulez
une forme de restriction de liberté
c'est à dire qu'il ne peut pas se rendre
sur un périmètre trop éloignés et il
garde un contact permanent avec la
gendarmerie mais il ya des alternatives
à tout ça il ya aussi le bracelet
électronique
kiki boké qui est une mesure j'irai de
qui est mise en oeuvre par des
magistrats de l'équipe quasiment une
mesure de semi liberté
je dire bon la sueur les suite justement
de la sphère judiciaire sur dans
laquelle il a été mise en cause on a
absolument aucune information c'est à
dire qu'est-ce qu'il a été condamnée est
ce que l'enquêté toujours en cours
s'il enquête est toujours en cours
depuis ses nombreux mois pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle n'a pas encore abouti malgré la
flagrance de ces éléments et aujourd'hui
voilà il est trop tard je veux dire
clairement
mais si vous voulez sur sur le statut de
réfugié politique il faudra aller aussi
un peu plus loin c'est à dire qu'on
accueille des personnes qui viennent de
zones de guerre de parfois effectivement
il ya des personnes polytraumatisées qui
est qui qui viennent se réfugier en
france mais a parfois aussi des gens qui
recèle en deux une violence et ça ça
nécessite justement une expertise parce
qu'on a eu le cas également sur la
sphère samuel pâtit où la personne était
bénéficiaire justement du statut de
réfugié